RICK NEEDHAM: Thank you everyone
for joining us today on our,
I believe, third, final,
some might argue best event
that we have sponsored here in
Mountain View for Veterans Day
activities.
I'm here as a representative
our Veterans Network.
I'm Rick Needham.
I work in energy
and sustainability.
But here today I'm really
meant to kind of introduce
Jake who's our honored
guest here today who
wrote this awesome
book, "Take Command."
I suggest reading it.
It's got some really cool
lessons, even like puts them
in really bulletized
form at the end,
so if you really want
to get through quickly,
you can, but lots of
really cool insights.
This is, as I mentioned,
a series of events
that we have around
Veterans Day.
People sometimes get
confused between Veterans Day
and Memorial Day.
So Memorial Day is meant to
honor those who have fallen.
Veterans Day is meant to
honor those who've served.
It actually started off
as Armistice Day, which
is based on the final day of
World War I. It's changed names
and dates a couple of times.
After World War II
it changed a bit.
But basically, it's a way of
honoring those who have served.
And we have a lot of
people within Google
who have served-- a lot
of people here today who
have served, both Jake and
members of Team Rubicon.
So it's an important day.
Another interesting important
day, especially to Jake
and to Ben who's going to
be moderating the talk,
is the Marine Corps
birthday, which
was earlier this week,
the 239th if I'm right.
If I was a Marine, I'd
definitely know for sure.
Oh, there's someone there
who can verify that.
So in addition to
the events that we've
had with respect to
Veterans Day at our offices
here in Mountain
View and worldwide,
we also launched
just this week a site
that highlights hiring
of veterans at Google.
That's been a lot
of effort that's
been put into that from
our veterans network.
We're really excited
about the site.
It really shows in the
words of David Drummond,
that "the doors are open
at Google for veterans."
And we want to make
sure that that's known,
and that people
who may have people
that they know who are
veterans to encourage
them to apply to jobs at Google.
Again, doors are open.
Here at Google, we recognize
the value of diversity.
And veterans is one
of those communities
that we certainly reach out
to as a way of bolstering
our own employee
base and getting
the prospective and
the skills that they
can bring to bear
for our own business.
The site, just in case you
want to go there, is g.co/vets.
So I would recommend
going there.
It's really cool.
But recognizing the value and
the skills that veterans have
is something that
probably resonates
pretty well with
our guest speaker
today with Jake who, when
he form Team Rubicon,
really was able to pull
from the veterans community
to provide a really interesting
opportunity for them
to continue to serve in
a really powerful way.
So before I talk about a
bit about Team Rubicon,
first a little bit about Jake.
Jake served as a sergeant
in the Marine Corps
with deployments in both
Iraq and Afghanistan
as a scout sniper.
So people hear Marine
sniper, that was Jake.
He was a Marine sniper.
He received a lot
of awards in combat,
was the honor graduate
of the recruit training
from school of infantry and
Marine scout sniper course.
And then in 2010, that's
when he, with a former Marine
William McNulty,
founded Team Rubicon.
Jake has been-- and I'll talk a
bit about more of Team Rubicon,
but Jake has been a really
outgoing advocate of veterans,
about issues facing
returning veterans,
and has been on numerous kind
of US committees on this topic,
and has made a lot of progress
and been a very strong voice
for the veterans community.
Prior to all this work, Jake was
at the University of Wisconsin
where he got his
bachelor's degree,
where he played four
years of varsity football,
and as I hear also weighed 295
pounds, which as you can see,
Marine Corps sniper training can
really take the pounds off too.
That's one way of doing it,
if you want to go that route.
So Team Rubicon-- so when
Jake formed Team Rubicon,
that was in 2010.
It was when he saw
what was happening
in Haiti, with the disaster in
Haiti, and he thought, my gosh.
I can go help out.
I can do something.
So Team Rubicon basically
formed, literally,
in the hours after that
disaster to be a team that
can help deliver veterans
to disaster zones
where they could really use some
of their skills and experiences
to not only help but
to feel like they're
continuing the
service, continuing
the service to something that's
beyond just what they can
do as individuals, but
something beyond themselves.
So it's really a pretty
powerful organization
that taps into the
strong desire of veterans
that we've seen
here at Google too,
the desire to work on
something that's bigger
than just themselves.
Today Team Rubicon-- and
this is maybe out of date.
This I think I read from the
book, but they've been growing.
So today boasts over two
dozen full time employees,
scores of part time
employees, and I
think it's over like, is it,
20,000 volunteer veterans
and first responders, so
an enormous organization,
a lot of it from volunteers,
many of whom are here today.
Not 20,000.
So they've engaged
over 50 missions
by the end of last year, on
four different continents.
They've been,
obviously, to Haiti,
but they've gone to places
like where Hurricane Sandy hit
in New York and New Jersey.
They'd been to places like
South Sudan and Burma.
They've been into the Midwest
when tornadoes have hit.
So they've gone into all
kinds of disaster zones.
They've won a lot of awards.
They won the National Small
Charity of the Year Award.
They also won the Heroes
and Leaders National
Award, the Grinnell Prize.
And in 2012, Jake was
named a CNN hero too.
So if you didn't want
another accolade,
there's another one for you.
So I did have a chance
to read the book.
And I think there was
a lot of things in here
that resonated not only
with, I think, veterans,
but also resonated well with how
we think about doing business
here at Google and how
we think about employees
and how do we think
about work environment.
A couple of things that
really stuck out to me
is one, really
focusing on people
who don't see just
obstacles but see solutions.
So here at Google,
we certainly prize
those employees and those
folks who really are thinking
not just about the
issues that we'll face
or the challenges we face,
or the competitors we face,
but really think about,
what are the solutions
around those things?
Focusing on the people who
don't just look at problems
but conjure up solutions,
who look at obstacles
and see only opportunity.
And this is the one quote
I really like for the book,
that they don't ask why
we would do something,
but they ask why not?
And I think that's a culture at
Google that exists at Google.
I mean, who would think
a search company would
go make a driverless car, or
would make a wearable device,
or do many things we
do, genomics research?
All these people would
consider crazy things.
But it's because
we're a company that
doesn't ask the question, why?
It's a company
that asks, why not?
Why can't we go do that?
And I think that
really resonates
with some of the things that
the Jake had in his book,
"Take Command."
Also another one,
action is often
the first step
toward a solution.
So to me, translating
that into Google
speak, we launch and iterate.
We do things, find
out what worked,
what didn't, modify
it, make it better,
and we're continuously
improving.
But if you get stuck in just
the continuous analysis,
you never actually
get to do something.
So we're very much
a culture that
focuses on doing and improving.
I think that also resonates.
And one other thing that stood
out for me is Team Rubicon
has a culture of a
lot of transparency.
And talking with Jake
just before this,
I didn't know that part of
the roots of that transparency
actually come from
something that Google does,
our TGIF, that happens every
week, where the founders get up
and talk to the
entire employee base
and are able to answer
questions from anyone
who wants to have the courage to
stand up and grab a microphone
and ask a question.
They do that with their
employees, internal employees.
They also do it
with their donors,
where they share not just
their successes but also
the challenges that they face.
And that's, I
think, an indication
of a very healthy organization
and one that can really thrive.
And although we can hear
it directly from Jake here,
I think one of the key themes
of why Team Rubicon really works
is that it affords
the veterans a way
to continue their dedication
to service and a dedication
to doing something, again,
that's bigger than themselves--
which is, when we think
about things at Google,
we tend to hire people who not
only are good at their job,
and can make the
next great product,
or help build out our
infrastructure that delivers
products and services
to a billion users,
but they tend to be
people also think about,
how can I make the world better?
What I'm working on, it
could be good for Google.
But I want it to be
good for the world.
I want to make the
world a better place.
And that to me felt
like also another way
that we kind of resonate
with the way Team Rubicon
thinks about gathering up
people who really have a desire
to do something much
bigger than themselves.
So we'll hear
directly from Jake.
But in order to elicit these
key insight and golden nuggets
from Jake, we also
have someone here
from Google who's going
to help moderate, Ben.
He's the head of
mid-market sales
and small medium business in
America for Google for Work.
He's been here
almost seven years,
so that's a long-time
veteran in Google years.
Ben also is a Marine.
He led Marines in Fallujah.
He has his own Purple
Heart from an RPG.
So he's been there.
And a connection that Jake
has with Team Rubicon I think
is actually twofold,
beyond just being Marines.
And Ben relayed to me that,
although he wasn't a Marine
sniper, he very,
very much appreciated
when they were around to
help support the infantry.
So he's certainly very
emphatic about that.
The other thing is
that Ben actually
spent time volunteering
with Team Rubicon
in New York with respect
to Hurricane Sandy.
So he got to see firsthand
some of the things
that Team Rubicon does.
So a great avenue to
getting some of these
nuggets out of Jake.
So I won't take anymore time.
I probably took too
much time already.
But let me introduce you to Jake
and Ben who can help moderate.
So thank you so much
for being here, guys.
[APPLAUSE]
BEN BUDDE: Thanks, Rick.
I appreciate it.
I'll just ask Jake to start off.
Please, introduce
yourself and then--
JAKE WOOD: Get into it?
BEN BUDDE: Yeah.
JAKE WOOD: All right.
Jake Wood.
How many people here are
Team Rubicon volunteers?
Awesome.
Googlers, Google vetters?
Vet Googlers?
All right.
Well, thank you
for your service.
Hopefully we can
turn all of you guys
into Team Rubicon volunteers
by the end of this.
Really excited to be here.
Very, very happy to be
on the Google campus.
I was not as excited when
my alarm went off at 6:00 AM
on the East Coast this morning
after being at a Metallica
concert on the National
Mall last night,
celebrating Veterans
Day, which was awesome,
the Concert for
Valor last night.
We got to rock out with
some pretty sweet bands.
But no, I really am
happy to be here.
And we were talking
beforehand why
it's actually pretty
cool to be here.
Because I, no kidding,
three years ago to the day,
I got a phone call from someone
at Google, a woman I known
named Carrie Laureno,
who has been a long time
big part of the vet net, or
the internal vet network here.
And it was the day
after Veterans Day 2011.
I had just been at a
Monday Night Football game
between the Green Bay Packers
and the Minnesota Vikings.
I'm a huge Packers fans.
So you can imagine the
state of mind I was in.
And I'm boarding a plane early
in the morning, probably 8:00
AM again.
And I get a phone call.
And she says, Jake.
We are about to release
our last grants for 2011.
Somebody that we were
going to give money to
just fell through.
I want to give
you money, but you
have to have a grant proposal
in to me by the end of the day.
I'm like, oh my god.
I feel like shit, Carrie.
You're going to make me write--
So I wrote this grant proposal
on the way from Green
Bay back to Los Angeles.
I hit Send as soon as I landed.
And Google became our first
ever corporate sponsor
about two weeks later.
Gave us $150,000 back
when $150,000-- I mean,
that's always a
big sum of money,
but back when $150,000 was an
organization-changing amount
of money for Team Rubicon,
so pretty cool to be here,
actually and make it
all come full circle.
So Team Rubicon, it was touched
on in that introduction,
is really an organization
about service.
And we do a lot of things.
But really at the
core of it is service.
And my journey toward
service actually
started as kind of a
journey away from service.
Back when I was a
junior in high school,
I thought I was going to
join the Marine Corps.
And I had all these
posters up in my room,
you know, Marine Corps posters.
I'd go steal some off the
recruiter's desk every time
he'd come into the cafeteria
looking for suckers like me.
And after my junior
year of high school,
I realized I had
this opportunity
to go and play
football in college.
And so I had these two
competing opportunities
for what I wanted to
do after graduating.
I ended up choosing to go to
college and play football.
I went to the University of
Wisconsin, showed up on campus
there in 2001.
And that was my dream.
My dream was to go on
and playing in the NFL.
I played offensive line.
At the time-- well, and
I'd like to think still--
Wisconsin is the best offensive
line school in the country.
And I got there, and we all
know kind of what happened.
Well, the first thing
that happened was I
realized that I was actually
a pretty terrible football
player, despite
being 295 pounds.
They wanted me at like 320.
And I just couldn't
physically do it.
And I'm made of glass.
So I show up, and after about
the second or third week
of the season, 9/11 happens.
We all remember 9/11.
I remember waking up.
I was in my dorm room.
I went down to the
cafeteria, saw everybody
huddled around the TV.
And it was a powerful moment.
And everybody knew that we
were going to be at war.
And I had this
first moment where
I was second guessing my
choice to come to Wisconsin
and pursue this thing,
this football thing.
My dad calls me that afternoon.
He says, don't even
think about it.
Stay in school.
And I thought long
and hard about it.
And I stayed in school.
And we went to war
in Afghanistan.
A year and a half later,
we went to war in Iraq.
And I'm sitting there
every day, and I'm
watching on CNN from
my dorm room young men
just like me in the
Battle of Fallujah.
Were you there in 2004?
BEN BUDDE: I was.
JAKE WOOD: So I was
watching this guy kick
in doors, 4,000 miles away.
And I'm sitting there
eating mac and cheese,
trying to get to
315 pounds still.
And it weighed on me.
Now, it didn't
weigh on me enough
to drop what I was doing to
go and join the Marine Corps.
But it weighed on me.
And then about a couple
months later, Pat Tillman
was killed in Afghanistan.
And that for me was the
moment where I said, OK.
It's time to stop
serving yourself
and start serving your
country like you've
been talking about for the
better part of the last four
or five years.
So I walked the graduation
ceremony, got my degree.
And I went over the
recruiter's office
and I enlisted in
the Marine Corps.
And that's really where
service kind of began for me.
I served in the Marine Corps,
did my first tour in Iraq
and the Anbar Province in
2007 as part of the surge.
It was with a unit, a battalion
out in Southern California,
2nd Battalion, 7th Marines.
And it was a tough tour.
My second week
in, I was actually
a young fire team
leader, a lance corporal.
My squad got hit.
One of my good
friends was killed.
Our squad leader was
wounded pretty badly.
That night I saw what
bad leadership was.
I was the junior fire
team leader in that squad.
But the senior fire
team leader, who
should have been taking charge
of that situation, he failed.
He hesitated.
There was this moment of
uncertainty in his eyes.
And so I ended up
taking, pardon--
I ended up taking command
of the squad at that moment.
And I received a
promotion to corporal.
And I led that squad then
for the next seven months.
Two weeks of combat experience.
And I learned
very, very quickly,
although I'd always thought that
I was a decent leader, that I
didn't know shit
about leadership.
Seven months trying to
motivate 13 young men
to suit up every day and go
outside the wire in the Anbar
Province during the
surge was tough.
And there were a
lot of failures.
And it continued be a tough
tour for seven months.
But I got back.
And I had a decision to make.
I ended up choosing to go into
the sniper platoon-- trying out
and being selected to
the sniper platoon,
and had an opportunity
a couple months later
to go to sniper school,
which is challenging.
It's got the highest dropout
rate in the Marine Corps.
We started with 32 guys, and I
think 15 or 16 of us graduated.
And that's after a pretty
cutthroat selection process
to get there.
And about a month
after graduating
from sniper school, my
little six man team,
within our platoon, we got
deployed to Afghanistan.
We got sent to the
Helmand Valley.
This was before Congress
authorized the surge
in Afghanistan.
So this was a really interesting
time to be in that country,
because it was
really understaffed,
under equipped, under supported.
And the Marine
Corps, particularly,
didn't really have
a mission there.
But they were trying
to give them one.
So they send this
battalion of Marines
into Helmand Valley, first
time US troops had been there
in about three or four years.
And my sniper team was attached
to a Marine infantry company.
And we were given
the city of Sangin.
So we had about 150
Marines to control
the city of Sangin, which
about two years later required
almost 2,000 Marines to control.
And we needed 2,000
Marines when we were there.
We got our ass kicked every day.
And it was tough.
Got back in '08, and
decided to get out.
I felt like I'd served.
I felt like my service
was over, rightfully so.
I served honorably,
done everything
that I wanted to do
in the Marine Corps.
But it was a tough
decision nonetheless.
You're waking away
from a mission
that, although it was
vague and ambiguous,
was still incomplete,
nonetheless.
And so it was a
really tough call
to get out at that
point in time.
But I got out in '09, wanted
to be an entrepreneur,
as if you can just go check a
box and become an entrepreneur.
But I knew I needed to go
and get some more schooling.
You know, it's tough to just
come out as a Marine sniper
and go and apply to
be an entrepreneur.
So I started to apply to a
bunch of different grad schools.
And in January 2010, I
got a rejection letter
from Stanford, which sucked.
And about two or three days
later, the Haiti earthquake
happened.
So that kind of gets us
to the point of the story.
I had never thought
in my life that I
would work for nonprofit.
I'd always been service minded.
I did different hunger drives
during high school and things
like that.
But I never thought I'd be in
the nonprofit space at all.
But I was siting
there, and I was
watching what was happening
in Port Au Prince.
And my combat experiences
was still so recent.
So as I was sitting there,
watching these images come
across the TV, it was just
like a second 9/11 moment.
And this time I knew that
I had the opportunity
to really serve
and have an impact.
And so together with
another Marine, actually
a college friend
of mine as well,
who is now a
Milwaukee firefighter,
we organized this
team of eight people.
And we got down to Port Au
Prince about four or five
days after the earthquake
and didn't really know
what we were going to do,
didn't have a solid plan.
The only map we had
going down I ripped off
the back of a Wall
Street Journal
on the flight to Miami
that had some arrows on it
about where supply depots
were inside Port Au Prince.
I mean, it was
pretty rudimentary.
And we didn't even
know how we were
going to get from the
Dominican Republic into Haiti.
We just knew that
we weren't going
to figure that out
by Googling it.
We'd have to get to Dominican
Republic to figure that out.
So we end up getting there.
And we cross the border
into Port Au Prince.
And for the next three weeks,
we run medical triage clinics
all across the city.
So we're setting up these mobile
clinics in the hardest hit
areas, going to places that
before the earthquake were
too dangerous for people to go.
And after the
earthquake were-- most
people assumed they were
even more dangerous.
But in reality,
they really weren't.
I mean, you had a population
that was desperate and shocked,
but they were also
in need of care.
But after about
two weeks of this,
William and I looked
at each other.
And we just said,
you know, all we've
been doing is using
counter insurgency
tactics to deliver
humanitarian aid.
And that seems kind of
weird to think about.
But it was the truth.
These principles
that had been drilled
in us in the second half of the
Iraq War, how to, as they say,
win hearts and minds
to defeat the enemy,
things like working with
the local populations,
employing locals, winning trust
by engaging community leaders.
And just these
things that we'd been
doing in these tribal villages
in Iraq and Afghanistan
was exactly what we were doing
in these rough areas of Port Au
Prince.
And so as we were thinking
about that, we said, OK.
Let's see where
we can take this.
You saw in Haiti just how broken
the disaster response industry
is.
It was slow.
There was a lot of
great innovation
that came out of Port Au
Prince, but by and large,
a lot of these organizations
were ripe for being overhauled.
The tactics that they were
using were antiquated.
And so we said, OK.
Let's change disaster response.
Let's build an
organization that is
capable of doing
this quicker, better,
more efficiently,
more transparently.
And so we organized or we
incorporated Team Rubicon
when we got back.
And our mission, as
we thought about it,
was to change disaster
response by using the skills
and experiences of
military veterans.
So we did that in 2010.
We went to places like
Chile after the tsunami.
We went to Pakistan after
the terrible flooding
there in Punjab
Providence in 2010.
We did humanitarian missions
in South Sudan and Burma.
And along the way, we kept
deploying these really
specialized troops, guys that
had been SEALs, or Recon,
or Rangers, that had
significant experience overseas.
Because we were sending people
into some pretty dangerous
places.
But they were all
coming back and they
were saying the same
thing, that this
was the most incredible
opportunity they'd each
had since they took
off the uniform.
They'd say, I never thought that
I'd feel this way ever again,
that I'd ever use those
skills that I learned
in Ranger school, or
special forces school,
to help people again.
And so we started
thinking about it.
Wow, this powerful.
And at the same time, we
had all these veterans
that had jobs in the
military that we didn't
have a use for overseas, people
that were maybe in bulk fuel
specialists, or water
sanitation, just jobs,
missile repairman, right?
And we're like, we're not
firing Tomahawks anywhere,
so we don't need
you to go to Burma.
We need a medic.
So missile technician doesn't
really fit the mission profile.
But it was obvious that
they needed an opportunity
to serve again.
And we were hearing
from the people
that we were deploying
that the opportunity was
in fact powerful.
So we started to look at how
we could expand our programs
to get more veterans
more involved.
And we started to look at
different opportunities
and the urgency of the
situation came home to roost.
My sniper partner, and
one of my best friends,
committed suicide
in Houston, Texas.
And he'd been with us in Haiti.
His name was Clay Hunt.
He was a great, great guy.
And the thing I tell
people is that Clay, he
struggled with
post-traumatic stress.
He'd been wounded in combat.
He'd been shot, actually,
by an enemy sniper.
And so he struggled with that.
But he was dealing with
his post-traumatic stress.
What was really causing him
anguish was the lack of purpose
that he had in his
post-military life.
And so when the dust
settled from his suicide,
we knew that that's
what we could do,
that we could provide--
we had to provide.
It wasn't that we could.
We had to provide a mission
for these veterans that
could provide that purpose
and that community for them.
So shortly after Clay's
memorial service,
the Tuscaloosa tornado
happened, the first one.
It was devastating.
We had no idea what we would
do for a domestic operation.
We had no idea what the
mission profile might be.
But we knew that, one,
there was a huge need.
And we knew that, two, we were
adaptable and nimble enough
to go down there and
find a way to plug in
and at least do something,
and along the way
discover what that
mission profile might be.
So we deployed, knocked
it out of the park.
It happened to be the
same week that Osama bin
Laden was killed in Afghanistan.
So I'm sitting there
with 20 guys and girls
around a campfire in
bumble fuck Alabama.
I mean, this was like banjos
in the background Alabama,
at this hunting cabin
and drinking whisky.
And we hear the word that
bin Laden's been killed.
So it was a pretty
poignant moment
that actually
brought some closure,
I think, for a lot of
people to everything
that had been happening.
I couldn't imagine a more
fitting setting for that news
to have been broken.
So we launched this
domestic operation.
And over the course of the
last now, see, 3 and 1/2 years,
that's become the
mainstay of Team Rubicon
So since that point in time, the
domestic program that we offer,
where we now have these 20,000
military veterans and civilians
across the country
organized into 10 regions,
that's what we do.
We go into communities after
terrible crises have happened,
whether it's a flood, or
tornado, or hurricane,
a wildfire, you name it,
some sort of calamity.
And we're going to go
in there, and we're
going to help stabilize
that community
and help get them back
on the road to recovery.
And so you can
imagine that we bring
this-- we try to bring order
to that chaos that invariably
happens.
We provide a bunch of different
functions, post-disaster.
We go in, and we
collect information
and create intelligence.
We provide the command and
control that is often lacking.
And then we deploy
a bunch of grunts.
And we go in and we
kick down houses.
And we pull them to the curve.
And we help expediently
repair homes that need it,
that aren't going to
be catastrophic losses.
And through this, through
this mission that's exciting,
that's meaningful,
that's needed,
we're able to provide that
purpose and that community.
I mean, you see some
of these volunteers
here with the gray shirt.
The gray shirt has come to
symbolize this really powerful
ethos that we believe in,
the power of this purpose
that we can provide.
And really as I look at what
the organization can become
over the next fie 10,
hopefully 100 years,
is that we can penetrate
down to the community level.
And we can make
communities more resilient
by bringing leadership out
at the community level.
And so that when crisis
happens in the future,
whether it's a single home
fire in a neighborhood,
that when crisis
happens, that people
are looking to the military
veterans in their community
to lead them through it.
And we hope Team Rubicon
can play the role for them.
We think we can.
We think we're getting there.
But that's really
the long term vision
that we're thinking about,
how can we get there?
And so along the way,
we've learned a lot.
It's been a classic
entrepreneurial journey.
I mean, we've had
fits and starts.
We've made mistakes.
We've hit some home runs.
We've had dwindling
cash flows and had
to make really tough decisions,
hiring people, firing people.
And it's been a challenge.
I mentioned when I first
was talking about Iraq
that I thought that I was a
good leader prior to Iraq.
And I quickly learned
with one explosion
that I didn't know
shit about leadership.
I left the Marine Corps thinking
that I was a good leader.
And entrepreneurship slapped
me in the face and said,
you don't know shit
about leadership.
And so, it's been another
journey over the last five
years as we approach in the
coming months our fifth year
anniversary.
But I think that some
of the lessons that
we've learned in building
Team Rubicon, I think,
can translate.
I think they can transcend
just what we're doing.
And that's what I tried
capturing in the book,
if anybody that's
read it thinks so.
I'd be happy to hear that.
But anyway, that's
what we're doing.
I want to kind of open it
up to you then, I guess.
BEN BUDDE: So such an honor
to have you here, Jake.
And thanks, Rick,
for the introduction.
It was just outstanding.
A little bit on format, guys.
So I'll ask Jake a
bunch of questions.
And then we'll pass
around the mic.
So start to think
about those as well.
Jake, let's talk more
about disaster response.
I'm super curious.
I think you articulated
well the value
of what Team Rubicon
brings to the table
and what you guys
really represent.
But there's all
these other NGOs that
are working in the
disaster response world.
How in the world
can you coordinate
to come to an effective solution
and collaborate together?
JAKE WOOD: Yeah, so
it's always a challenge.
Every disaster is unique for all
the reasons you might imagine.
Every community's unique.
Every disaster itself is unique.
The resiliency of the
structures are unique.
So each situation is
entirely different.
It's been a journey for us.
When we first got into
the domestic space,
the domestic disaster
response space
is-- and
internationally as well.
It's a bunch of large
legacy organizations.
And it's a bit of a
good ol' boy club.
A lot of these people have
been in disaster response
their entire lives.
They all know each other.
They show up in
Joplin, Missouri.
They're all shaking hands
across organizations
because they see each
other 10 times a year
in 10 different cities.
And so when we were just
an upstart organization
that nobody knew about,
nobody wanted to know about,
say in a situation
like Joplin, we
couldn't get a
seat at the table.
So we would have to go
into these communities.
And we would have to-- we
would try to coordinate.
We had a lot of doors
shut in our face.
So we would go out
of the community,
and we would try
to identify a need.
And we would serve
that need with humility
and professionalism
until we got to the point
where fewer doors were
being shot in our face.
And at least some
conversations were happening.
The real watershed moment
for us was Hurricane Sandy.
We'd started to build a
reputation domestically
over about the year and a
half prior to that event.
We'd started to
build relationships
within the New York City
office of emergency management,
specifically.
So we were actually
pretty well poised
when that storm made landfall.
We actually had
somebody staffing a desk
in that office when
it made landfall.
And so we were immediately a
part of the official response.
And for us, that was one of
those moments in our startup
journey where we had a
dwindling cash reserve.
A week prior Sandy
hitting, I remember
sitting down with our
accountant and saying, OK.
OK, we got two or three
months of cash left.
What bills are we
going to stop paying?
Who can we stretch out?
What invoices can we ignore?
And started having
those discussions.
So when Sandy happened,
massive event, massive
need, but massive
opportunity, if your business
is responding to disasters.
So we knew we had to put
our chips on the table.
Because we knew the world
was going to be watching.
We knew that if
we went out there,
and we put all the
chips on the table,
and if we hit it
out of the park,
somebody was going to notice.
And so like I said, we
are well-positioned,
because we were already
working with the OEM.
But we put all our
chips out there.
We ended up having a lot of
really, really strong winds.
And we've got some people that
were in Hurricane Sandy-- I
guess yourself included--
that were there.
And so after Sandy, we started
to get a seat at the table.
People started to say, OK.
Well, veterans in disaster
response, that makes sense.
OK, so tell us.
More and we started
to make some changes.
We learned a lot of
great lessons after Sandy
as well that we were able
to implement in 2013.
So now how it happens-- we've
gotten ourselves at the point
here at the end of 2014 where
all these other organizations
have allowed us this
seat at the table.
We are a voice that people
will listen to in the space.
But what we also
learned was there
was a void in the national
framework of disaster
response at the NGO level.
You have the American Red Cross.
The question I always
get is, how do you guys
compete with the
American Red Cross?
Well, the answer is
simply, we don't.
The Red Cross provides mass
care and mass sheltering.
So they go in they set up
these massive shelters.
If a bunch of homes are
destroyed, they'll go in.
They'll set up in a gymnasium.
They'll put a bunch of cots out.
They'll set up shower facilities
so that all the homeowners who
no longer have a home to
go home to have a place
that they can lay their
head at night that's safe
and that they're going
to be well fed in.
But the Red Cross isn't
going to go to your home
and take the tree that's
sticking out of your roof
where the water's pouring
into your living room.
But nonetheless, you'll
have people standing
on their porch
saying, where's FEMA?
And where's the Red Cross?
And why aren't they getting
this tree out of my roof?
Well, it's because
that's not what they do.
And there's actually
not a whole lot
of national non-governmental
organizations that do that.
Typically what happens is that's
neighbors helping neighbors
or it's contractors going
in and fleecing people.
So if it's neighbors helping
neighbors, that's great.
That's good.
That's American
values right there.
But those people aren't going
to be bonded and insured.
They're not necessarily going
to know the standard of work
that's going to be
needed to conduct it.
There's no guarantee that,
again, not knowing standard,
that it's going to be
done the right way.
So what we're able to
do from that function
is go in and provide a national
level of standardization
and command and control to
conduct those operations so
that we can stabilize
that homeowner
and make sure that they
are worried about dealing
with insurance, and claims, and
all of that, and not worried
about the next thunderstorm
that's coming through and going
to dump two inches of rain
through the hole in their roof.
So we can go in and
make sure that that's
stabilized for them.
One of the other things that's
been really cool that we've
been able to do is bring--
because of, I think,
are two things, our
youth as an organization
but also the type of
people that we have in it.
We have been able to
bring new technologies
to bear in this that have
made some real differences
in disaster response.
Anybody here know of
the company Palantir?
I mean, it's-- yeah so.
If you're in tech, you
probably know who Palantir is.
We've got a great philanthropic
relationship with Palantir.
So we will go in,
and I mentioned
that one of the
functions that we provide
is collecting information
and creating intelligence.
And so you can imagine a
tornado rips through a town.
And it takes out a half
mile swath for two miles.
And it rips up all these
homes and businesses.
And it's destroyed.
Well, nobody really knows the
level of destruction early on.
And what organizations
typically will do
is they'll go deploy
these people out on foot.
They've got these paper tablets.
Every organization's working
off a different form,
a different intake form.
And they put in this
information home by home.
And they're on different
pieces of paper.
And they go and they dump
these pieces of paper
somewhere at a command center.
Lord knows what happens
to the information on it.
I doubt anybody's collating
it and making any sense of it.
I think it's just
kind of a check
in the box for
some organizations.
And it gets thrown into
the back of the room.
And no actionable intelligence
is generated from that.
Well, what we're doing
is working with Palantir.
We have these mobile
phones that are loaded up
with their software, the mobile
version of their software.
We go house to house.
We're able to put
all the information
in on a FEMA standardized form.
That's, of course, cloud-based.
It's getting sucked up into
the cloud, sent back down
to our technicians at our
forward operating base who
in real time are mapping out
the disaster as it's unfolding.
And so we can then create
an intelligence picture
that other organizations
can look at.
And we can actually make
actionable, well-informed
decisions based off
of that information
that we're collecting.
Now the reason we're
able to do that is we
don't have any legacy
systems we have
to jettison in order to do it.
And second, like I said, the
people that we have staffing
these positions, most
of them veterans,
come from the best equipped, the
most technologically advanced
military in the
history of the world.
So whereas if you're a sniper
team on the battlefield
in Afghanistan and you want
to know what's going on,
you call in a drone.
And you might have a
snazzy little tablet
that you're looking
at a live feed of.
We expect that same
level of technology
enabling in the disaster zone.
So we're able to do that.
We're actively seeking out those
different types of technologies
and trying to implement them.
And along the way,
what we're doing is
we're changing the industry.
Like Palantir, it's
probably why we're still
in a philanthropic
relationship with them.
It's probably going to make
a lot of money off the stuff
that we're pioneering in
this disaster response space.
And so if we can make some
of these technology platforms
ubiquitous across
organizations, then we've
done that part of changing
disaster response.
Long winded answer to whatever
the hell your question was.
BEN BUDDE: No,
it's very cool what
you guys are doing to really
connect all these NGOs.
You mentioned Hurricane Sandy.
And yeah, I had the privilege to
go with some folks from Google
Veterans Network to
help volunteer there.
And I see some Google
vets in the crowd as well.
I'm actually not sure why
we've had such a great turnout.
Is it your celebrity
status or is it
because we promised
all of our vets beer?
JAKE WOOD: Yeah,
we're about-- yeah,
we're standing in
between vets and beer.
It's a dangerous position.
BEN BUDDE: But I think for me,
I was able to see on the ground
the benefit that
the Team Rubicon
folks were able to provide.
But it was just chaos
there, and just seeing
and walking the streets,
the aftermath of it.
It was really moving
and impactful.
And I did see signs
here and there,
even in New Jersey where
we were, that said,
looters will be shot on site.
I'm super curious,
as you guys have
done so many dozens
of missions worldwide,
how you evaluate the threat
and whether to deploy or not
from a physical
security standpoint.
JAKE WOOD: Yeah,
it's interesting.
The first time I ever
had a gun pointed at me
was not after I
joined the Marines.
It was before when I went
down to Hurricane Katrina.
That was my first taste
in disaster response.
I just went down there on a
whim with a high school buddy
and had a gun pulled on me by
a guy near the shores of Lake
Pontchartrain, because we had a
truck with out-of-state license
plates, right?
Damn Yankee license
plates, at that.
And he pulled a gun on us, and
we got the hell out of there.
But, it happens.
I think that one of the
things that we can lean on
is we have a uniform
when we go out.
OK, so there's an instant
level of credibility
that comes with that.
But the moment a
homeowner learns
that it's a military
veteran-based organization,
there's an instant
level of trust.
You look at polls that show
different federal and US
institutions and the
level of confidence
that the public has
in then, obviously
the Congressional line
is trending downward,
if it's not rock bottom yet.
But the one that's been
steady at about-- I'll make up
a number-- it's well over
80%, is the US military.
And so listen, I served
with a lot of shady guys
and a lot of assholes.
But by and large
for whatever reason,
we got a pretty
decent reputation.
And so when you walk up,
and you have a uniform on,
and you say hey,
we're Team Rubicon.
We're a veterans-based
organization.
We're here to help for free.
It disarms people.
And I will say, I mean,
some of these guys
have been on a lot more
missions than I have.
You'll have people just
break down in tears instantly
with the thought
of veterans coming
to help them in
their time of need.
It's pretty powerful.
It's pretty cool.
BEN BUDDE: That's awesome.
And then when you're
on the ground,
there are some of these
areas, you don't have power.
Or even getting food, water,
or a decent night's sleep,
I think, could
probably be a challenge
for some of the volunteers.
And it's very different
from the day-to-day lives
that we live every day.
Can you talk a little bit about
how you think strategically
in that environment when
it's hard not to think like,
when am I just going to
get a pound cake or like--
JAKE WOOD: A lemon pound cake.
BEN BUDDE: Yeah.
JAKE WOOD: So it's
funny you say that,
because we more often than
not will have members complain
that the deployment is too easy.
The first time I
heard that, I kid you
not, we were doing this
humanitarian intervention
in South Sudan.
We were partnered with
an organization called
International Medical Corps.
They've been around
since the '80s.
There a fantastic organization.
And they go into the
worst places in the world,
and, you know, big.
It's a $100 million organization
based out of Los Angeles.
They wanted our
veterans to help them
in this refugee crisis that
was blowing up in South Sudan.
and we were rotating teams
in, teams of five to eight
over the course of
about five months.
And I got a call from
the in-country director
from International Medical Corps
who said, your guys are crazy.
They got here, and they
literally gave up their cots
because they said--
they felt bad
that they were sleeping
on clots and complaining
and they weren't
sleeping in the mud.
So yeah, I mean,
Hurricane Sandy,
for anybody that was in New
York, you couldn't get fuel.
Water and power
were challenging.
We were sleeping in a massive
unheated warehouse in Brooklyn
in the middle of winter with
another nor'easter coming in.
It was getting down to
in the 30s at night.
And we had people sleeping
on cots, nobody complaining.
And what it is is
it's that feeling
that you're back in it again.
And there's something
that's nostalgic about that.
I think that the
men and women that
did that overseas, you never
stopped complaining about it
when you were sleeping
on a cot in Afghanistan
or on the ground in Afghanistan.
You never stopped
complaining about it.
But you get out, and you like
to think about how awesome you
used to be when you
were doing that.
And so we can kind of give these
people a taste of that again.
But listen, I think
it's also something
we pride ourselves on.
You'll hear organizations say,
oh, we're not going to go in.
The hotel rooms
are all sold out.
We don't know where we're
going to sleep our people.
It's like, come on.
There's people in need.
You're telling me you
would take a hotel room
when there are people whose
homes have been destroyed
and might need it?
I don't know if we've ever had
somebody stay in a hotel room
in the history of
our organization.
I don't know if we ever will.
I feel bad enough that I'm
sleeping in a hotel room
tonight.
BEN BUDDE: I think for the
benefit of the audience,
you know, Jake I had a couple
conversations in leading up
to this.
And I will say
that never once did
he talk about
himself or his book.
It was all about Team Rubicon.
And I'm so inspired by that
type of humble leadership.
I'm curious for you
what inspires you today
and who inspires you.
JAKE WOOD: Oh man.
You know, the stories-- if
you hang around Team Rubicon
long enough, you'll hear stories
that are just so inspirational.
You know, part of the challenge
of this organization growing
and professionalizing
is that I've
started to get more and
more isolated up at the top.
And that's tough, because
when I joined the Marines,
I enlisted versus
going officer because I
wanted to be in the mud.
And that idea of kicking
in doors leadership
is what I wanted.
And that's what I had in Haiti.
I was leading a small
team in Port Au Prince.
And in Joplin, I was leading
a small team in Joplin.
I haven't been on a
mission in two years.
But I hear these stories
that come out of them.
And it's inspiring.
We had a couple in Colorado.
We were responding to the
floods a year ago in Colorado.
And those were freakish.
Those were 150 year floods.
And we had a guy that
was medically retired
from the Army for
post-traumatic stress.
He has a crazy story
for what he was
doing with JASOC in
Iraq and Afghanistan.
He'd met a woman through
another organization
called Mission Continues.
And they had gotten engaged.
But he was medically retired,
so he wasn't working.
And so he was able to
spend about two or three
weeks with our teams in
Colorado with his wife.
And he was so inspired
by that mission.
This was his first real
Team Rubicon experience.
He was so inspired
by the mission,
he felt so at home with the
people that he was with,
that they threw away
their wedding plans.
They were six months
in the future.
They got married right there.
They got married by a TR
volunteer who was a chaplain.
All the witnesses
were TR people.
We set up in a
Home Depot parking
lot a chapel out of a
warehouse and buckets for pews.
And we had shovel bearers.
And they got married.
And that sounds kind of hokey.
But when you think
about it, here's
a guy that I don't
think he ever thought
he'd feel that
sense of belonging
and brotherhood again like that.
And I watched that live
on Skype from London.
I remember sitting there.
I got shushed by the
mother of the bride who
was also on Skype.
I felt really bad about that.
But it was unbelievable.
And the thing that-- we used
to think about how we measure
our brand or how we measure
the power of the identity
a Team Rubicon.
And there's a lot of vanity
metrics that you could look at.
And sometimes they're exciting
like Facebook Likes and Twitter
followers.
But the first time I saw
a Team Rubicon tattoo,
it was like, OK,
that's interesting.
But person's probably a weirdo.
And this is a heavily tattooed
organization to begin with.
So I'm not sure it's that
weird or out of place.
Then I saw another one, and
another one, and another one.
And we've got three dozen
people with TR tattoos.
And I think that when you
evaluate whether you've
built something that really
matters-- whether it's Google,
whether it's Team Rubicon--
is if it went away overnight,
other than the people that are
financially dependent on it,
would anybody give a shit?
So we've got 28 employees
down in Los Angeles.
Obviously, they would
care, because they
have to pay their bills.
But would the other 20,000
care if Team Rubicon just
disappeared?
And it forced us to
really look at that
when we start seeing
these tattoos,
and say, like, yeah, OK.
Well, they've got tattoos.
So that would be awkward
for the rest of their lives.
But I think we've
build something
that would leave a
void in people's lives
that I don't know that
they could easily replace.
And that's inspiring.
It's a lot of pressure.
Now but it's inspiring.
It adds pressure, but it
also relieves pressure.
Because it indicates
that there are
people that are willing to
go to the ends of the world
to make this
organization succeed.
What we've built is
the product of-- now,
I think we just last night,
because of this Concert
for Valor, eclipsed
20,000 volunteers.
And we've got 20,000 people
that will not let it fail.
So that's-- I guess that takes a
little bit of the pressure off.
BEN BUDDE: For sure.
Congrats on the milestone.
Yeah, super inspiring story.
I think there's this notion
of social entrepreneurship.
And I think you've
done an outstanding job
with Team Rubicon.
Can you talk a little
bit about just what
that means in the world
of social entrepreneurship
and the connection
that you're having
with vets as they
transition out.
JAKE WOOD: Well, I think
entrepreneurship is changing.
There's a lot of
different companies
that have kind of turn the
model of what entrepreneurship
can and should be on its head.
I mean, look a guy
like TOMS Shoes.
You've got Blake, the guy
that runs TOMS Shoes who just
sold a controlling
interest in it.
So he's not doing
bad for himself.
I think the guy just had
a $300 million windfall.
But he's changed an
industry so that people
expect to see social good
come out of the corporations
that they align themselves with.
So social
entrepreneurship I think
is changing, whether it's
a for-profit non-for-profit
model.
And we certainly, as we
look at the next three,
to five, or 10 years,
we want to get out
of the begging for
money business.
We think that we can maintain
our nonprofit identity
and our service
identity and still
monetize some of the
functions that we provide.
And we want to do that.
We're trying to
move towards that.
Because again, I
think that is going
to be the next
expectation of nonprofits,
that they're not
begging for money,
that they're finding a way to
provide real value in the world
and make money off it
that can sustain them.
So what's it mean for veterans?
I mean, you have 2 and
1/2 half million, roughly,
veterans coming back from
Iraq and Afghanistan,
the majority of whom joined
the military at one of the most
critical ages that
they'll deliver hit,
that 18 to
22-year-old age frame.
It's the transformative period
of so many of their lives.
And so they join at 18.
They get a uniform.
They get a job.
They get an identity.
They get a mission that is
probably-- reasonable minds
could argue-- but one of the
more noble missions in life,
wear the uniform of your country
and fight for your country.
And they do that for four,
six, eight, 10 years.
And they get out,
so many of them
became men, became women,
during that point in time
alongside other men and women
experiencing the same thing.
You rip them out of that, and
you might give them a job.
They might come and
work for Google.
Maybe they're a
mechanic in Portland.
But does it have the
same sense of purpose
and does it bring with
them that same community?
There's a reason why all of
these Fortune 500 companies
have all these veterans
affinity groups.
You guys like each other.
You want to be around
like-minded people again.
So I do think that
social entrepreneurship
and organizations like Team
Rubicon-- not just Team Rubicon
but like Team Rubicon-- can
really help fill that void.
I mean, I talk about it
as like a purpose cliff.
You're 24 years old.
You've bee in the
Army for six years.
You get out.
You've got a job, but
maybe it's menial.
And you move back home.
You're not with any of the
people you served with.
Your high school friends
have all moved on
or they have their
families, whatever it is.
Where are you going to
find your purpose in life?
Whether veteran or civilian,
having purpose in your life
is the key to happiness.
I think that the
challenge for veterans
is that they've had
such a purposeful life.
How do you maintain
that post-military?
That's the challenge,
because it's perhaps
the most purposeful life
that you could lead.
So you yank somebody
out of that at 25 years
old-- that's a challenge.
And I think that there's an
opportunity for organizations
like Team Rubicon, like
Team Red, White & Blue,
and some others in
the veteran space,
to come in and help fill
that and shepherd people
through that period
and transition
to the next period
of their life.
BEN BUDDE: That's fantastic.
And in the book, you talk about
this a little bit as well.
Something I loved
about the book,
it wasn't just about history,
or your experience, or business.
It was really these common
trends across all of them.
I remember one
business story you
were telling about a hedge fund,
a private equity manager-- just
an extremely successful
man-- and he was thinking,
I think I just
want to quit my job
and just do something
more purposeful.
But in the end, your
message and lesson
from this decision
he was going through
was you don't actually
have to quit your job
and join a nonprofit full time
to have a purposeful life.
JAKE WOOD: Right.
BEN BUDDE: Can you
talk about that?
Like, are the roles for
Googlers here and people outside
of Team Rubicon to really
make that connection?
JAKE WOOD: Absolutely.
So this guy was one of our
first major private donors.
And yeah, he's a great person.
He's very religious.
He's tithed at least 10% of
his income for his entire life.
And this guy makes
a lot of money.
So he's given a lot
of it away every year.
And he went to his pastor--
he told me this story.
He went to his pastor, and he
said, I want to quit my job
and become a youth minister.
His pastor said,
you're an idiot.
You're giving me a half
million dollars a year.
Leave it to the professionals.
You keep making money,
which the only thing
in the world that
you're good at.
And you keep giving it to me,
and we'll do good with it.
And he had to come to terms
with that was his purpose.
And he finds value in that.
I think that what I go on from
in the book from that story
is that you don't have to
rush off to Port Au Prince
to find purpose, or Joplin,
or any of these things.
This shouldn't be
preaching about purpose
and you have to go
and live as a pauper
and do good deeds for
the rest of your life.
I imagine that working as a
nuclear tech on a submarine
and now helping a
company like Google
reduce its energy footprint
in a period of time when
this whole climate change thing
is hanging over everyone's
heads, and people to probably
don't know that technology
companies have enormous
energy footprints.
That's purposeful.
There's an opportunity there to
find value and purpose in work,
even though it's for
a for-profit that's
publicly traded, that you're
probably making good money at.
There's absolutely purpose to
be derived from that mission.
There's purpose to
be derived from just
working at Google in general.
I mean, think about how
Google has changed the world.
One, I can win any bet
instantly because I
can Google any of the answers
that I think is right.
But beyond that,
Google has contributed
to revolutions that are positive
in parts of the country the
never thought they'd see
things like democracy before.
People that are
working at Twitter
can hang their hats
on the Arab Spring.
And so I think people
just have to understand
the value that they're
bringing in the world
and see that through
the lens of purpose.
But if you can't find
it in your job-- say
you work in a meaningless job in
a windowless basement cubicle,
and you can't possibly
find it, you probably
should go coach a Little
League team or something
and get it somewhere.
I think it's important.
BEN BUDDE: Awesome.
Let's talk about
teams a little bit.
It sounds like you're
part of some great ones,
really, as a collegiate athlete,
the Marine Corps, Team Rubicon.
What do you think is
the common thread?
What makes a great team?
JAKE WOOD: I think it's--
boy, there's a lot.
There's a lot to
get into in teams.
I think, though, if you have a
vision that inspires everybody
on the team, that's
the most basic tenant.
You have to have a vision
that everyone on that team
aspires to accomplishing.
I think we have that
at Team Rubicon.
It's moved a little bit.
It's changed.
It's evolved.
But at the end of
the day, I think
we have people that have
bought into the vision of what
we're trying to do.
And so good teams
need great leaders.
Great teams require them.
But at the end of
the day, that leader
is really only
there to articulate
that vision and that mission
and continue to put it out
in front of people's eyes so
they see it every single day
and they're working and
aspiring towards it.
Other than that, get out of
the way and let the team do it.
So I think if I had to boil
it down into one thing,
it would be vision.
But there's a lot that
goes into building teams.
I talk a lot about
it extensively
in one of the chapters.
But I mean, the thing, when
I go and I talk to companies,
that I most often talk
about is building teams.
So there's a lot
that goes into it.
We don't have the
perfect recipe.
We're still tweaking it.
But I think we've
found a hell of a team.
BEN BUDDE: And getting the
right people on the bus.
JAKE WOOD: Yeah, I mean Jim
Collins sold $20 billion copies
of a book talking
about building teams.
So yeah.
BEN BUDDE: Absolutely.
So I think we all have
stress in our day-to-day,
and you've certainly
seen your fair share.
I'm curious how you're
able to just kind of rise
above and navigate the ambiguity
and really take command.
JAKE WOOD: Man, you know, that's
what sniper school is really
designed to drill out
of you is the ability
to handle stress, rise above
stress, see things clearly.
One of the things
I talk about is--
I actually learned
prior to sniper school
from my old football
coach at Wisconsin
who used to scream
it all the time.
But he used to say,
control the controllables,
which probably isn't
even proper English.
I'm not sure.
But he he'd say, control
the controllable.
And he would say it in the
context of football games,
where you were facing things
outside of your control,
be it weather.
I mean, we played at Wisconsin.
We played in a lot
of bad weather games,
whether rain, or snow, or sleet.
It's easy for teams
or for players
to dwell on those things.
Oh, man, it's raining out.
My cleats are going
to slide on the grass.
The ball's going to be
slippery, all this stuff.
Well, shit, if you spend
all your time worried
about all those
things that-- you
can worry about that
till the cows come home.
You are not going
to change the fact
that that ball's
going to be wet.
So draining your mental
faculties on that
instead of thinking
about, OK, so how are
we can execute, because that's
something we can control.
How are we going to maintain
a positive attitude, all
these other things.
I think not focusing
on the controllables
is the quickest way to
fall back into the fray.
It's maybe not the key
to rising above it.
But it's the key to
falling back into it,
if you find yourself above it.
So I think that's
always critical.
I often find myself in
stressful situations,
yelling at people to stop
worrying about those fringe
concerns that are
beyond their control.
Because-- and this is
just my personal opinion--
I think that people, they
focus on those things
when they're scared about the
entirety of the situation.
And they kind of hide behind
those uncontrollables.
People that really succeed
in ambiguous situations
are the people that just go
after and attack the things
that they can
actually influence.
So that's one of the things
that, when I found myself
in really bad situations,
and not just bad
situation like Afghanistan,
but bad situation in business.
It's, hey, stop
worrying about that.
Focus on, that is our
singular problem right now.
All these other 10 things?
Hey, they suck.
That's our problem.
BEN BUDDE: And that's
the one we can control.
JAKE WOOD: And that's the
one we can control, so focus
everything on that.
BEN BUDDE: Great advice.
So I'll have one more
question here for Jake.
Please start passing
around the mic,
thinking about your questions.
At Google, we're big on
moonshots and thinking 10x
and what that like--
JAKE WOOD: I thought you were
going to say moonshine, sorry.
[LAUGHTER]
BEN BUDDE: We haven't gotten
into the moonshine business,
but really thinking of what
that ideal solution is.
And I'm curious, in
a world, hopefully,
in the future we can predict
or prevent to some extent
natural disasters.
But until that happens,
what's the ideal kind
of crisis and disaster response
world look like to you?
You touched a
little bit about it,
about engaging folks
from the community.
I'm just curious what you think
10, 20 years down the line.
JAKE WOOD: Well, the buzzword
in the industry right
now is resiliency.
And so that touches
on everything
from infrastructure
resiliency to community
and behavioral resiliency
after disasters.
Disasters, you can
call it moonshot.
I don't think we're ever going
to find a way to prevents them.
I just don't think
that's going to happen.
I don't think even
Google could do that.
So they're going to happen.
We shouldn't focus on
trying to stop them.
Because that's uncontrollable.
I truly think the greatest tool
in any disaster is leadership.
Now preparedness is important,
but that requires leadership.
Action in the midst
of is important.
You've got to have
all the tactics
and resources necessary.
But you've got to have
leadership to deploy them.
The recovery-- the immediate
recovery situation--
is critical, setting up
the long term recovery.
And it requires, again, good
plans, and good resources,
and at the end of the
day requires leadership.
So how do we make sure that
we're putting good leadership
in place in advance
of these things
and that we have good
leadership in place
to lead us through them?
Not every military veteran's
a good leader, flat out.
I served under a lot of terrible
leaders in the Marine Corps.
I was a bad leader at
times in the Marine Corps.
So I'm not trying to
say that we should just
find veterans and put them
in leadership positions
in order to lead us through
times of chaos after disasters.
But I do think that there are
very, very good leaders coming
out of the military, and
they're repopulating counties
and communities all
across the country.
I think they're looking for
an opportunity like this.
And I think we should
engage them to do it.
So I think, what's
the key to making
us better at responding
to disasters?
Yeah, resources are important.
Plans are important.
All of that stuff is important.
Without leadership,
none of them matter.
So let's focus on leadership.
That's what we're trying
to focus on anyway.
BEN BUDDE: Outstanding.
And I think one thing I
love about you in your book
and even in your
talk today, you're
so open and honest
about your failures.
And you're ready
to learn from them.
And you're super
transparent about that
in your organization.
And for me, my experience
of military leaders,
there's been great ones and
ones that could improve as well.
But I think there
is that potential,
because that common
thread amongst all of them
is like, we just want to learn.
And we're OK to
fail along the way.
So let's go ahead and
pass the mic around.
Anyone have a question for Jake?
Please.
AUDIENCE: I know a lot has
evolved over the last four
years, 4 and 1/2 years, since
you started Team Rubicon.
But obviously you
have it perfected,
the natural disaster response
overall program as a whole
also.
What's next?
I mean, where do
you see Team Rubicon
in two years, five
years, 10 years.
Or maybe a better question
would be, what's missing?
Maybe it's not even Team
Rubicon that fills that gap.
Maybe it's grooming
another organization
or nonprofit to come
in, similar how--
Team Rubicon, like
you said, removes
that tree from the house.
That was a void that's
there for a long time.
And now that that
void is filled,
there are other voids I'm sure.
I'm curious if you've
identified them.
JAKE WOOD: Yes, so, looking
out over the next five years,
we want to, I guess, kind of own
the life cycle of a disaster.
So we are in the response
business right now.
When bad things happen,
we go in and respond.
Because of our mission, though,
of veteran reintegration,
we know it's important
for the organization
to be reaching out to and
meaningfully engaging veterans
in between disasters.
Because we can't
predict when they're
happening, with the duration,
or who could be involved.
So what we started to
implement this year
was a training program,
training pipelines,
so we're engaging veterans
between in more of a readiness
aspect.
So this is a meaningful
way to engage our veterans.
It's creating that community.
It's helping them to
think about the mission.
So it's providing
them that mission.
They really actually
feel like they're
raising their right
hand to serve.
It's making us,
of course, better.
I think that as a
component of readiness,
in addition to
training, we're going
to be looking at resiliency.
We're looking at best in
class resiliency models.
The one that we are
really in love with
is one based out
of Mira Loma here
in San Francisco
that we're really
looking at how we can take that
framework and rubber stamp it
in cities and communities
across the country.
So that's going to be an
important, I think, next phase.
The phase that I think is
exciting for a lot of people
to think about is that
third leg or that third part
of the wheel in a disaster's
life cycle, which is recovery.
We don't do any long
term recovery right now.
So we take that tree
out of that house.
We'll patch it up.
But we're not going
to repair the roof.
That requires real skills.
I mean, you need
carpentry, roofing,
things that are
resource-intensive,
certification-intensive,
things like that.
But it provides for
us an opportunity
to have a long term engagement
with a certain portion
of our membership base.
It also provides
us an opportunity
to get into an
employment aspect.
I think one of the tragedies
of the initial roll out
of the post 9/11 GI Bill
was it didn't allow veterans
to take it and go
to trade schools.
It forced veterans into
four-year college programs.
It's since changed.
But what that did was it sent
veterans who were probably not
suited for college for a variety
of reasons-- not everybody is.
I think it's one of the great
tragedies of our education
system that we try to
make everybody think
they have to go to
college to be successful.
So I think there's
a real opportunity
to engage transitioning
veterans in the trade crafts.
I think that we can
do that and do it
under the auspices of more
of a recovery battalion.
And so we can send in a response
team, stabilize a community,
and then we'll bring in
these men and women who
are learning real trade
skills to come in and get
a federal or state contract
to help with the long term
six to 12 months recovery phase.
It's real meaningful
work opportunities,
employment opportunities.
And hopefully we could
work with organizations
to have employment transition
to full time careers afterwards.
But in my opinion, it solves
a couple of social issues.
It addresses veterans'
unemployment, transition
training, but also this void
in real necessary trade skills
that's happening
in this country.
Aside from the
veteran issue, that's
a real problem in this country.
And we're not
going to tackle it.
We're talking about maybe a
couple hundred, maybe 1,000
veterans a year.
But I think it's more of
the philosophy behind it.
So that's, I guess,
an example of what
we're looking at over
the next five years.
AUDIENCE: So you touched on
briefly about the challenges
early on dealing with
more powerful NGOs
and getting a seat at the table.
And during Hurricane Sandy, that
was like your breaking point.
Can you expand a little bit
about how your organization
overcame the large
barrier to entry
and became a respected NGO?
JAKE WOOD: It's
is still journey.
I think they were doing a
really good job of it now.
But we had to treat every
opportunity, every disaster
that we responded
to prior to Sandy,
like it was our Super Bowl.
And that meant going all
in on each one of them.
That meant trying to be as
professional as possible and as
humble as possible.
So what we would do is
we'd walk into a community.
We'd go into a community, and
we'd find the person in charge.
He would have no
idea who we are.
We'd walk up.
Our incident leader would
walk up and say, hey.
I'm Jake Wood.
I'm from Team Rubicon.
Here's how many people I have.
They're mostly
military veterans,
which again, instantly at least,
OK, now they're intrigued.
They're going to listen to you.
Here's what we can do for you.
You could have us go take care
of this neighborhood over here.
Or you can tell us
to go shovel shit.
If you tell us to
go shovel shit,
we'll be the best shit
shovelers you've ever seen.
And we meant it.
We would be willing to take on
any task that was given to us.
And most people,
once they found out
that we had young,
strong, able-bodied vets,
chances are that it was a
police chief or a fire chief
that we were talking to.
Good chance that person's
a vet his or herself.
So there was that level
of familiarity there.
We weren't just
another church group
that was a bunch of 14-year-olds
led by a 24-year-old youth
minister.
No calluses on anybody's hands,
never worked an honest day
in their lives.
So I think we were a
breath of fresh air.
But that being said,
a lot of people
still didn't want to
trust us at the beginning.
You're talking about communities
that are very vulnerable.
Looters are a problem
in these situations.
People that are coming
in and scheming people
with bad contracts
are a problem.
So it was challenging.
But it was approaching
the industry
with humility and
professionalism.
And it's weird,
because I don't really
consider us a
humble organization.
Social media, we like to be
very boastful of what we do.
I think we've towed
the line pretty well.
But we're humble
when we need to be.
Again, I think that
kind of comes back
to a little bit of that
military tradition.
I was a sergeant in the Marine
Corps, on the enlisted side.
But every once in
a while, I'd have
to go up the battalion
commander and sell
a mission in Afghanistan.
You have to know how to
walk up to somebody that's
in a position of authority,
and be deferential, but also
be strong in your conviction,
and able to articulate why.
Here's why we need
to do something.
And I'm not unique in
having that experience
in the military.
A lot of these young men and
women have the same thing.
So I think that's
served us well.
AUDIENCE: Hi, Jake.
So one of the questions I
have is, as a former Marine ,
we all know that "hurry up
and wait" is something--
it's just instilled in us.
We're ready, ready to go.
And we're just sitting
around waiting.
I've been involved
now for six months.
And one of the
things I notice is
that there's not enough
natural disasters-- thank
God-- for all of
us to get deployed.
And I know that
the organization's
grow really, really fast.
How fast do you see
it continuing to grow?
And are there any
programs that-- one
of the things that I felt
very closely was I also
had some friends that didn't
find their sense of purpose
in life.
I'm self-motivated.
So for me, it was
easy to find something
I'll substitute
the corps within.
And that camaraderie
was never substituted.
Now I feel that whenever I
engage with other veterans
and volunteer at the hospital
or something like that.
I get a little bit of that back.
But is there plans to,
while people are waiting,
maybe engage the VA into--
JAKE WOOD: That disaster?
AUDIENCE: No.
[LAUGHTER]
JAKE WOOD: Sorry,
I couldn't resist.
Sorry.
AUDIENCE: VA Palo Alto
and VA SF are incredible.
JAKE WOOD: Yeah, they are.
AUDIENCE: I do vouch for them,
because I tried VA in Atlanta
once.
And that was like walking
into a Civil War Museum.
But regardless of
that, just engaging
some maybe psychologists
or professionals in therapy
to actually engage the
groups and the teams
and the people that are
joining in as the group
grows really fast
and we're sitting
around waiting for the next
possibility to volunteer.
JAKE WOOD: Yes, so I'll
actually challenge your premise
and say that there are
plenty of disasters happening
every day in this country.
We currently don't have
the systems or capacity
to respond to them.
So we aren't
currently constrained
by the number of disasters
that are taking place.
We're constrained by leadership
at the regional and state
levels, equipment, and
systems and process.
So what I mean by
that is there's
been a disaster
within 50 miles of us
where we're sitting right
now that Team Rubicon didn't
respond to in the
last six months,
be it a wildfire, a
small flood that just
didn't make the "San Francisco
Chronicle," or a lost hiker.
And so what Team Rubicon needs
to do is engage leadership,
continue to engage leadership,
as low a level as possible.
That requires time, because it
requires systems and process
in order to hold accountability.
It requires standards to
hold people accountable to.
And we're still
developing those things.
I mean, you'll ask
some of the people who
have been around for a little
bit longer than others,
and we've come a long way
in the last 18 to 24 months.
So the first thing I'll say
is that you'll be surprised,
I think, over the next 12 months
the disasters that you never
realized were happening
in your own backyard.
And you'll find yourself
responding to them.
I never knew that
disasters were happening,
and now I get a threat
briefing every morning
when I wake up from
our planning section.
So that's the first thing.
I think what you'll
find is that there
are plenty of opportunities
of tragedy and crisis
around the country, happening
every single day in states
and communities all
across the country.
The second thing is,
yeah, absolutely.
And we are engaging
other organizations.
We've got a great relationship
with Team Red, White & Blue.
There's a representative
back here.
We think physical fitness is
a core pillar of preparation
on a personal level.
And obviously, we're deploying
people into, sometimes,
more tough than
other situations,
where physical fitness and
capability is important.
I think there's
real value in that.
We have a great relationship
with a mental health
organization called
Give an Hour,
and we're placing Give an Hour
points of contacts or liaisons
within each of the regions,
hopefully at the state
level over the course
of the next 18 months,
depending on funding so
that we have that bridge.
What we're doing is we're
deploying those mental health
professionals alongside
our teams into communities.
Kind of the the
stated objective there
is that they are there for
the people whose lives have
been devastated by the disaster.
But of course, if
our people want
to bend their ear at the
end of the night, that's OK.
And in between missions as well.
So we're big believers in
maintaining a core focus
on what we're doing.
You'll hear us up
at headquarters
say that "do what you do best.
Partner for the rest."
So we're not going
to get into designing
a bunch of programming that
isn't core to what we do.
But we want to partner with
great organizations who
can help fill that void, I
think Team Red, White & Blue
being a great example.
Does that answer your question?
AUDIENCE: I've another
growth question.
So one of the challenges
here at Google
is how do we grow but also
stay very nimble, and creative,
and flexible, and running an
organization that prides itself
on response time,
and where hours
make such a huge difference.
How do you guys grow
but stay nimble?
And then how do you
maybe leverage technology
to kind of help get spun up
before a disaster strikes,
whether through modeling
or things like that?
JAKE WOOD: Yeah, I think
it's a great question.
I'd love to turn
it around to some
of the senior
executives at Google
and ask how you
guys have done it.
We battle that
question all the time.
We have leaders within
our organization
who have questioned
the direction
the organization's
going at time.
When we were going to
places like Joplin,
we were rushing in there, 15
guys, a couple of chainsaws,
24 hours after that thing hit.
We'd stick around for
four, five, six, seven days
before somebody kicked us
out, and then we'd go home.
OK, well, we got there
and we prided ourselves
on being there in 24 hours.
Now it might take a 72 hours
to go to that same operation.
The reason is we're liaising
with government officials.
We're making sure
that we've got--
laying the groundwork for
a forward operating base.
And we'll hear
criticisms from people
saying, why are we
getting in there?
Why aren't we getting in there?
And how I'll respond
or how we will respond
is that we're not looking
for speed for speed's sake.
There's such a
thing as just simply
going after speed for
the sake of vanity.
We're not going in the Joplin
to do search and rescue or life
safety operations.
We're going in to
stabilize people's homes.
And the difference
between 24 and 72 hours
is really negligible.
But the foundation that we're
able to lay over those 72 hours
allows us to stay for two,
three, four weeks instead
of two, three, four days.
And so when you
balance out, OK, what
is the net good that
has come of this?
OK, I think the 72
hours is still quick.
We're still bridging a
gap in that response.
But that extra 48 hours
doesn't really matter.
But it is a challenge.
I think what it requires
is in the military,
you talk about the
strategic corporal, at least
in the Marine Corps.
And the strategic
corporal was this concept
that came out in the
mid '90s, General Krulak
was talking with some pretty
high level of prescience
that in some war in the future,
we'd have to rely on a corporal
to make these critical
four block warfare
decisions on the grounds
in some unforeseen country
that we don't yet know.
Well, fast forward 10 years
from when he said that,
and we're in Iraq,
and we're relying
on the strategic corporal
in the streets of Baghdad.
So the reason why
that's important
is because the
ability for a general
to trust a corporal, who's
probably 19 years old,
maybe has a high school
diploma, certainly
probably does not have a college
degree, the reason a four star
general can trust that
19-year-old fire team
leader with making a critical
decision that has implications
that are theater-wide,
whether to shoot that speeding
car coming at them,
whether to hand out
$1,000 cash to some guy who
claims that a missile killed
his donkey, you have to
trust that they understand,
one, the mission, the
method of getting there,
and the importance of
every decision they make,
and what the standard is
for success along the way.
In the book, I talk about
commander's intent--
it's something that we
talk about all the time--
articulating what we want to
see accomplish, what that end
state looks like,
then allowing people
to accomplish it on their own,
with their own strategies,
with their own tactics.
That's what we're
working towards.
But what it requires is at
least a general framework
for how we do everything.
Once you have that loose
framework in place,
some people call
that bureaucracy.
But listen, at the end
of day, bureaucracy
can either liberate you
or it can burden you down.
If you use bureaucracy
to eliminate
the thinking or the decisions
that you shouldn't be spending
time and mental energy
on, then it liberates you.
If you hide behind bureaucracy,
then it's burdening.
So you can look at the
framework for decision
making one of two ways.
And it really depends on the
type of leaders that you are.
So we're trying to
build a framework,
and we're trying
to recruit leaders
that use bureaucracy to
liberate their decision
making versus something that
they're going to hide behind.
And if you're hiding behind
bureaucracy and process,
then you're probably not going
to last a whole long time
in Team Rubicon.
And technology's critical at
every layer of what we do.
We're bringing in some
really awesome technology.
And we're in the
implementation phase for a lot
really, really
cool things, things
like we've got this new
software platform that's
a tracking tool.
And I mean it's
nothing groundbreaking.
But it basically is allowing
us to dispatch guys and girls
from across the
country to an incident
and track them in real time as
they're getting to the rally
point, and making sure that
we have full accountability,
and able to see on a
battle map where everybody
is at every single time.
And they instantly fall in
credential to their hierarchy.
And it's pretty cool stuff.
A couple of innovative fire
departments are using it.
But we're the first
nonprofit organization
to start adopting it.
And so what that allows you
to do is let people loose.
Because I know that I can
just log onto my computer
and have instant accountability.
So that's one thing--
that's one less
thing that I have
to worry about.
Technology, it's just critical.
It is.
BEN BUDDE: Awesome,
well to wrap it up,
I want to say I'm so thankful
to have such an honorable guest
and a wonderful organization.
So if you're part
of Team Rubicon,
please do stand up now.
We'd all love to thank you.
What you guys do for our veteran
community and for our world
is just simply unbelievable.
So please join me in welcoming
them with a round of applause.
[APPLAUSE]
And to Jake, yeah.
JAKE WOOD: Thanks for having me.
BEN BUDDE: It's been an honor.
It's awesome.
I will say, so "Take Command,"
Jake's new book, is out.
We have 30 free copies, please.
We can all dog pile
on the way to those.
After those 30 run out,
there's subsidized books here
that [INAUDIBLE]
has for you all.
So I'll leave the last words
of wisdom to you, Jake.
Thanks again.
JAKE WOOD: The Team
Rubicon people are probably
going to rush the bar
pretty soon, so the line--
[LAUGHTER]
The line for the books
will be pretty short,
just as you think
tactically about how
you want to do things.
No, I really appreciate
the opportunity.
I mean, to think that three
years ago I was the hung over
guy on a Delta fly trying to
pound out a grant proposal is
pretty interesting,
actually, pretty timely.
No, but it has been great.
Google's been a great
partner of ours.
And I really admire
Google for being
innovative in the
veteran transition space
before it was cool for
all these corporations
to be in the veteran
transition space
as a corporate social
responsibility platform.
I mean, Google has been
at it for a long time.
I think that's pretty cool.
I think it's something you
guys should hang your hats on.
And on top of that,
Google is just
a very responsible
company in society.
And you guys should
all be really
proud and honored to work here.
I would be remiss if
I left without saying
that as a nonprofit,
we are always
looking for financial support.
We just got done
running a campaign that
ended yesterday
called 11/11, trying
to encourage people
to donate $11 a month.
Don't want to be car salesman
up here, but if at the end
the year you're looking
for a good organization
to put your money
to work, we think
that we put it to work
as well as anybody else.
So we'd love to
have your support.
And more importantly we'd
love for you guys to sign up.
Because we are not
just exclusively
a veterans organization.
We have a ton of
civilians that work
alongside our vets every day.
And they're a critical,
critical part to what we do.
And you guys would
have to show up
Palantir when you go out there.
And I know there's probably
some jockeying and ego
thing that goes with that.
They are definitely more geeky
than the people I've seen here.
But that's it.
BEN BUDDE: Awesome.
Thanks, Jake.
I really appreciate it.
[APPLAUSE]